knowledge maybe smart intelligent
brilliant and in terms of your people
you know all of us oh my gosh I want to
be so smart I want to know how
competency that's what I want right well
last week I had three top recruiting
firms came in town one from New York one
from Chicago went from Maine Corinth
berry which is the top of the top Russel
Reynolds which is uh I think number two
or number three on any given year and
another one that came from Maine we're
looking looking for to recruit a new CEO
for the company and they started asking
me questions and one of these ladies one
of the ladies that was with Korn ferry
asked me so many questions with great
questions so tell me in the past have
you ever hired somebody that didn't work
out
yes what caused it you know what could
you have done differently all these
other questions and as she finally says
you know what Patrick here's what we
said current fairy corn Feria so what's
that people get hired for what they know
and fired for who they are we say one
more time people get hired for what they
know but fired for who they are so what
does this mean to me
well I am right now in Palm Springs in a
twenty five thousand square foot home
okay I mean we're gonna have a hundred
forty people here tomorrow we'll be
entertaining and at the same time for
four days all we'll be talking about is
how to process issues together how to
make decisions together obviously we're
gonna have a good time we'll have chefs
will have people cooking for us we'll
watch movies there's a massive 2:34
swimming pools outside and we'll have a
good time but the main theme we'll be
working on is a part of how to decision
making process and more importantly
we'll be working on developing people on
who they can be because the moment that
lady told me that people get hired for
what they know and fired
for who they are it made me think about
well sometimes if you don't know how to
deal with people who cares how much you
know if you don't know how to lead
people who cares how many degrees you
got if you don't how to handle stuff
when there's fire and challenges and
issues and pressure
no one cares how much you know no one
does
and so in 2019 while you're getting
prepared for 2019 and we're sitting here
we're getting ourselves prepared for the
meeting that's gonna be taking place
tomorrow
what time is it right now by the window
can you tell us what time it is it is
almost midnight but we left Dallas at
six seven o'clock in the morning so
which means it's 2 a.m. and it's 2 a.m.
yeah it's to him in Dallas right now but
you know why I'm so excited about this
meeting we do every single year because
every time the entire purpose here is to
figure out ways to make better decisions
and at the same time help develop better
develop better leaders that when you go
back dealing with people you get better
results so whatever you're thinking
about this holiday season as you're
preparing for great 2019 don't just stay
focused on what you know spend a lot of
time also asking yourself who you are
and would people want to lead and follow
someone like you and if you feel there's
areas you got improvement which is
always address those issues because 2019
it's all about leadership not just about
what you know
anyways let's have a killer week
everybody take care bye-bye